Les amis, Bienvenue dans le dernier épisode de The Last Guardian, ..
.. Souvenez-vous, à la fin de l'épisode précédent..
.. Trico avait fait une terrible chute après son combat contre... l'autre Trico.
Trico venait d'vomir le miroir..
.. Qui va nous permettre sûrement d'accéder à un endroit où choper de la bouffe !
Pour le remettre en état de marche, parce que là il est vraiment pas bien quoi...
A mon avis il y a un truc à... Regardez bah voilà..
.. Cette fameuse chaîne putain.
Alors, Il faut qu'on dirige ça tout là-haut..
.. Et est-ce que Trico en a la force ? Ouais ! D'utiliser son petit pouvoir..
.. Nice !
C'est bien mon Trico.
Allez courage mon grand, j'arrive.
J'espère qu'il y aura au moins 4 barils mon gars.
Qu'on lui offre un festin !
Ouais doit y avoir des trucs dans les décombres..
.. Alors, Oh ouiii ! Putain ! On a jamais été aussi content d'en trouver.
Hop là ! Parfait j'ai réussi à lui foutre dans la bouche. (Hum, Hum)
Ca va te mettre bien.
Allez le petit deuxième..
.. Hop là le deuxième ! Parfait mon grand.
Alors. Est-ce que tu vas te lever ?
Faut que j'aille en chercher d'autres ?
Ca va suffire ?
Bon. Il a pas l'air de réagir. Je pense qu'il lui en faut plus. De toute manière, y'a pas 36 chemins. Là-bas aussi..
.. On peut escalader. On va aller voir si il y a plus de bouffe.
En même temps là, il a pris tellement cher que... Ouais, il va lui falloir..
.. Au moins 3 ou 4 tonneaux pour aller mieux quoi.
Niquel! Je suis en train de monter- Oh!
Merde
Wow j'aurais pu mourir bêtement. Ah ! J'ai vu d'autres tonneaux
Ah mince, je me suis évanoui! ... Ouais...
Le temps s'est un peu écoulé
On est tous les deux mal putain
Un bobo au crâne hein
Allez Trico j'arrive. On peut entendre son coeur battre en plus. C'est horrible!
On voit qu'il est vraiment mal quoi
Alors attends j'ai vu des tonneaux là-dedans...normalement...Tiens bah regarde
Y en a un là-haut
Hop là!
Un de plus et le petit dernier je te l'amène tout de suite il est juste derrière toi
Hop là! On est bons!
ça fait quatre
Est-ce qu'il faut encore que j'aille en rechercher ou ça va suffire?
On dirait bien que c'est la fin
C'est le début de la nuit. La fin de la journée
Ok nouvelle journée
Peut-être la dernière
C'est triste hein?
C'est marrant normalement c'est l'inverse c'est ton petit chat qui dort contre toi
Yes!
Yes il se lève!
La forme?
T'a tout donné hein
Yes!
Allez on va remonter. T'inquiète pas j'ai compris
On va tout remonter.- Mais oui!
Il le pense carrément là!
Oh ça fait plaisir! Regardez les grandes cornes qu'il à maintenant! Ah t'es adulte maintenant Trico
T'es plus le bébé qu'on avait trouvé hein!
Tu perds pas de temps. Putain il y va direct
yes!
argh, putain de saloperie
ah ok, je pense qu'il faut sortir le
miroir. vas-y défonces-le Trico
ça marche ou pas sur un enemie
après et pas qu'un peu
on va remonter tout ça mon gars
on va ré-atteindre le...
L'espèce de bâtiment bizarre qu'on
avait trouvé. On est parti dessus
très très bien Putain c'est super haut!
On a un grand chemin à faire et en plus faut que je fasse gaffe s'il y a des gardes à bien les démolir.
voilà je m'en doutais
Tu vises bien
Ouah !! Ok, on remonte
vraiment tous les niveaux d'avant
Quoi ?! C'est ouf!
Du coup, on va pouvoir péter la porte qu'est là, je suppose?
Ok, on est bons!
comme ça tu vas pouvoir sauter là-bas porte en faîte. A mon avis, c'est là-bas qu'il faut qu'on aille.
Okay! Toi, tu perds pas de temps, tu vas direct à gauche.
Bas, vas-y, je te suis, hein?!
Je te suis !
T'as... Ah Putain ! Nous revoilà dans ces
endroits à la c*n! On déjà passé
On déjà passé par là. Allez! Viens! Allez, mon grand tu peux le faire!! Vas-y !!!
Il ose pas, c'est ouf ! - Allez...
Yes !!
Est-ce que tu vas résister aux ondes?
ça va le faire, Trico ?
Allez, mon grand, Courage ! ça va ça va ça va! Vas-y, viens on peut le casser, tu penses, Trico, ça?
Allez vas-y, tu vas le péter
Bravo mon grand ! T'as résisté !
Putain ! Eh !! tu bas ta peur des miroirs. Ensuite tu
pètes le truc qui envoie des ondes !
Allez, on vas pouvoir y aller, mec !
On vas pouvoir foncer. Du coup, je propose qu'on tente de péter les
miroirs de loin
oui!! oh c'est bon ça
braaaaa comme dans star wars, c'est magnifique
et voilà, viens on va pouvoir s'envoler Trico
j'vais te faire confiance sur le saut j'sais pas où il faut aller
hey saute mon gars, non mais c'est bien ce que tu fais mais il faut que tu sautes, vas-y saute
tu continues t'as les capacités
mais tu les exploites pas
on a beaucoup entendu cette phrase. trouve l'angle trouve le calcul et on y va
et on y va
yes
parfais ça alors il va falloir que tu fasse du pilier par pilier pour piller ouais c'est
ça
allez va sur le pilier
voilà et on va tous traversés à l'aide
des piliers
pouvoir à l'armée
parfait mon grand!
encore un
ouais, c'est très bien
on est dedans, splendide
bon a mon avis on a pété ici 600 miroirs pour que ça soit pas le chemin a prendre.
donc Trico
tu vas venir là
et on va se barrer sur celui là
c'est comme une échelle finalement, c'est une échelle pour euh les gens comme Trico
pour les monstres qui font 40 mètres
c'est très bien il comprend tout seul je l'aime
ah et là ensuite t'as vu c'est a moi tout seul de faire ouais alors bouge pas je vais devoir y aller mon Trico
que je sais que t'es triste comme à chaque fois que je dois te laisser tout seul
mais on va très vite se retrouver comme à chaque fois que je continue tout
seul
regarde où ça mène sur une petite passerelle en bois le long du bâtiment
okay
oh putain
Oh putain !
J'ai failli me re-foirer
Normalement je peux l'atteindre celui-là on est d'accord il est pas trop haut
Ouais c'est juste moi qui me suis chier dessus juste avant quoi okay
Rien n'est trop haut
pour ce petit garçon de toute manière, c'est vrai
donc là Trico tu vas devoir nous rejoindre ici, je sais pas trop comment je vais pouvoir te faire venir
Ahhh je vais t'ouvrir la grille
très bien aller
ramène toi
on va devoir traverser le pont là grâce à tes skill de mec qui saute très très loin
Ouais !
Oh nan oh nan oh naaan
Oh nan oh c'est bon !
ah faut que je t'aide ? Nan c'est bon tu as réussis
Bien joué mon Trico !
T'as vu t'as grandis maintenant t'utilise tes ailes et tout et tu tombes plus
quand le pont s'effondre
Sachant que tout s'effondre en plus dans ce putain d'univers
On va pouvoir accéder à euh...
Cette petite passerelle qui va nous permettre de remonter via les trucs
comme celui-là avec des torches allez
vas-y viens
okay on est parti, yes
Ouhhh là j'ai un saut à faire mon gars, je vais compter sur toi Trico
Ah nan c'est bon tu peux, j'allais sauter, m'accrocher à la corde mon gars
la mort trop conne
C'est splendide Trico
Oh y'a des gardes, on se les extermine mon gars
Moins un
et moins deux, très bien
Oh mon pauvre
T'as fais un face-plant
Oh ça va ? On est en train de remonter vénère. Je suis sûr qu'à la fin
il va s'envoler et s'accrocher à la tour principale, c'est sûr !
Je sais pas où il te l'a mis (le pieu) je vais te le retirer juste après promis
ok on est bien il vas falloir refaire
un système avec de l'élan
je suppose. Ah mais ça c'est les grilles où je peux passer entre les barreaux
Mais me regarde pas comme ça mon grand je vais faire ce qu'il faut regarde là y'a des petites marches
ça va sûrement être pour t'abaisser le pont que y'a en face
ok on est en haut
est ce que y'a pas un système pour... Ah bah voilà !
ça va être pour activer
le grand pont en face
Et ben voilà c'est celui de cette tour là mais bon.Il était en train de mettre ses pattes sur le mur
Aller vas-y let's go, on te regarde faire le saut
C'est parti ok
On lui a demandé de voler mais je suis pas sûr qu'il puisse
Moi en tout cas je vais prendre le petites marches que y'a là
elles ne sont clairement pas là
pour rien
Okay et y'a un levier
En fait c'est bête c'est de là d'ou l'on vient ça a juste complété le pont
En fait. Ah okay !
C'est pour prendre suffisamment d'élan pour pouvoir s'envoler jusqu'à la tour principale
Ouaah... Prends ton élan !
Y'a du garde là !
wow
Wooow il l'a fait tombé
Okay on les a tous démoli, la maintenant Trico on va essayé d'aller dans la tour mon gars
Peut-être en faisant le tour par là ? Peut-être que l'espèce d'objet
qu'on avait trouvé là la dernière fois qu'on était sur ce bâtiment l'espèce de... Je sais pas
On dirait quelque chose dans lequel faut mettre un objet Peut-être qu'il faut juste
envoyer le miroir là dessus
j'suis sûr le pouvoir de Trico là dedans. On va voir
En tout cas c'était derrière
Aller viens viens viens Trico.
j'suis sûr c'est comme ça qu'on va accéder
faut mettre les miroirs ?
tout simplement
ah bah voilà
ça y'est
ça y'est on rentre là-dedans on va avoir
des réponses à nos questions
qu'es-ce ce qui se passe là dedans
tu viens mon grand ?
qu'est-ce qu'ils foutent ici
c'est beau
encore un truc dans lequel mettre le miroir
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
ça fait rien de spécial ah c'est un ascenseur...!
wow c'est dément...!
et je peux pas prendre ma queue ? aaah ok c'est à moi de prendre ta queue
on y va
j'suis sûr que c'est par là
nickel ça va aller Trico on a déjà vécu cette situation 600 000 fois toi et moi
et en plus ta queue elle pend donc je vais pouvoir quand même m'en servir pour démolir les...
....gardes qui vont se présenter à moi
alors
et bah regarde
y a des casques là c'est pas compliqué hein
tu prends les casques tu les fous dans l'armure et tu rejoins Trico pour qu'il les défonce
avec sa queue
vas y viens
ok j'ai juste à sauter les armures
savent pas sauter
et ensuite
je prends le miroir et je te rekt mon pote
il fait le malin... allez ...
c'est bon ça !
à bout portant mon gars aller venez tous comme ça on n'en parle plus ok
y en aura 2 où il faudra que je mette les casques
voilà qui est mieux, RIP mon ami !
voilà le dernier a bien implosé sa grosse race
on va pouvoir voir ce qui reste à
faire la avec les...
....les slots de miroirs, est-ce que tous les slots servent à la même chose ?
ah faut les activer en fait ok
on va continuer comme ça jusqu'a avoir tout activé
j'entends les pas d'un garde ça me stresse ah c'est le dernier je crois celui là
ça s'ouvre ! On arrive Trico
ça va nous mener tout en haut
ok Trico j'arrive, n'y va pas sans moi
ok on est bon direction la vérité c'est parti
oh la la la la ça va être fou fou
on va monter super haut
allez mon Trico
on va connaître l'origine de notre
existence
de TON existence surtout
attends on arrive dans une nouvelle salle je me méfie
y a plein de portes de gardes
ça sent pas bon du tout
et voilà
et voilà voilà voilà c'était sur
ce qu'on lui a mis c'est lui qui a fini dans la porte le con !
toi tu vas arrêter avec
tes putain de miroirs salop va... voilà dans le trou !
allez Trico régale toi là tu les démonte j'suis obligé de courir mon grand parce que
ils veulent vraiment me choper
ça va que je suis fort à l'épervier je mets des belles feintes mais...
oooh il les a tous démoli même moi mais c'est pas grave
allez il en reste quelque uns...
et l'autre avec son miroir qui n'a toujours pas réussi à le récupérer
ah ils sont drôles des fois
on l'a vu
allez je te retire les pieux et on avance mon grand...on les a rekt mon gars on est bon. ah bah là haut mec
y a un signe de miroir tout là haut...waou...bon ok
oh nan c'est un piège ?
oh le malin ! ah mais tu m'empêches d'y aller...
c'est pas grave nan c'est bon vas y vas y bien joué Trico !
oh t'as été trop malin mec !
ou est-ce qu'on est en train d'aller là...
attends mais ça monte pendant super longtemps là ya un truc à faire c'est pas possible
je peux vous dire que là on est au sommet sommet de la tour
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça...
ok j'ai déjà répéré un truc qui brille là bas, c'est de la bouffe, parfait
ah putain c'est que ainsi que des tonneaux de bouffe....
...déchiquetés
qui ont donc été mangé par quelqu'un et c'est pas Trico
vu que Trico n'est jamais venu ici et ya du bruit qui vient de...
ah ok c'est parce qu'il y a une hélice d'accord on est pas encore au sommet sommet
on va devoir monter Trico va falloir y aller de branche en branche tu tiens là dessus toi ?
mais oui regarde vas y. Nice mon grand
Nice excellent
Tu continues à monter
yes fait gaffe parce que bientôt il y aura la palme là qui va nous emmerder
Attend c'est quoi ça c'est un petit trou pour moi ça
Ok Trico j'vais aller voir ce qu'il y a là dedans et voir si elle adore ouais
c'est ça ç'est pour moi
t'inquiète t'inquiète j'arrive
j'vais voir ce qu'il y a
wow j'suis à l'intérieur
Le maître de la Vallée
d'accord
je dois le péter c'est ça ?
oui il aime pas en tout cas quand je fais ça
oh il aime pas du tout ok là on est bon là stop
allez let's go !
va falloir monter vite
putain
ok on est bon
hop on est bon
on va pouvoir s'accrocher au dernier truc
ah si vous saviez comme j'ai galéré à atteindre ce stade mon gars
ça fait 20 minutes au moins que je cherche
on va se retrouver en extérieur wow
et ça c'est les formes du coup qui rendent fou Trico vous savez qui envoient des ondes
c'est de cette matière-là
on va y aller
euh il faut sauter...
il faut sauter sur ce truc là qui va
super vite mais nan
wouah ok on est dessus
donc là
il va falloir qu'on aille
ah ouais par contre je galère à bouger
va falloir qu'on aille là où il y avait le miroir, j'ose pas aller trop trop vite
il est là !
on met ça là
on a arrêté le truc Trico il va pouvoir nous rejoindre c'est ça ?
J'crois qu'il a eu le temps de sortir je vais le rejoindre par là
t'es là ou pas Trico ?
attends j'arrive je vais sortir d'ici
est-ce que t'es là ?
j'aimerais bien te voir ouii t'es là mon grand !
t'es content qu'on se retrouve hein
t'es toujours content qu'on se retrouve
mec on est au sommet de la tour qu'est-ce qu'on fait Trico là
oh, cinématique
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il a envoyé un signal pour attirer les Trico
c'est quoi ce bordel
les ondes over puissantes
c'est là où ils ramènent les enfants...
et en échange le truc envoie de la bouffe
nan tapez pas Trico
ah du coup il va vouloir me bouffer pour avoir de la bouffe
il va m'offrir à la machine pour avoir de la bouffe
miroir miroir
il est où le miroir faut que je trouve le miroir mais je sais pas jusqu'où il a roulé, ah là bas il brille je le vois
le miroir il est là bas je le vois
Ok je l'ai
Oh il va lui déchirer...
Nooooon!
ok je vais activer la queue de Trico elle a du tomber dans le coeur je vais l'activer avec le miroir et ça va tout faire péter
laissez moi. à mon avis il faut que j'aille choper la queue
je vais la mettre à côté du coeur
du maître de la Vallée mon cul
et je pense que
ça va le démolir
parce que normalement ya pas la place pour qu'un Trico puisse aller là bas
mais vu qu'il lui ont arraché la queue putain Trico est en train de se faire dévorer vivant
c'est horrible....allez viens avec moi
tiens on tombe tous les 2
ok on va mettre tellement cher putain de coeur tiens saloperiie
allez en espérant que la queue de Trico te tire dessus
ça va faire mal
allez encore encore
comme Trico quand il s'est prit un coup d'éclair...
il est tellement mal en point...
il lui manque un oeil
ah il nous ramène au village
saloperie de jeu !
Eh ben est-ce que c'est pas la fin qu'on imaginait tous en fait?
que... ils soient séparés
la fragilité d'un homme
la première fois de ma vie que je...
My hearth is broken
eh bien voila les amis c'est la fin de ce let's play
c'était une putain de belle histoire
on a vu du coup qui était le grand méchant
on a vu qu'il y avait un milliard de tricos et qu'ils étaient tous sous
l'emprise de
ce grand méchant
qu'on a réussi a détruire
jusqu'au bout Trico il aura été fidèle et mignon
des larmes coulent, sur ce visage, ...pour une fois c'est pas de l'eau
ah les amis j'étais tellement a fond dans ce jeu
j'étais..j'avais tellement envie d'y jouer tout le temps
de voir la fin de l'histoire que...putain
mais tu sais c'est pas comme un film là c'est c'est quand même tu passes 11/12 heures
tu vois beaucoup plus de péripéties entre les deux persos
que dans un film en fait un film ça dure une heure et demie et là putain c'est vachement long
en plus ils nous calent des moments émotions avec des musiques tristes putain
là j’espère secrètement une petite scène de fin d'après générique
où on voit Trico qui
je sais pas qu'il vient déposer un...
un tonneau de bouffe au pieds du village, j'en sais rien pour montrer qu'il est en vie quoi
c'est la fin du générique ça se termine sur le miroir. est ce qu'on a une scène de fin s'il vous plaît?
ça dézoom
oh oui
voilà ce qu'on appelle un chef-d’œuvre tout simplement
ben voila les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo et de ce let's play c'était super
merci a tous de l'avoir suivi
je m'attendais pas à ce que vous soyez si nombreux a me suivre
vu que c'est un jeu assez long assez...enfin voila c'est de la poésie ça a rien a voir avec les jeux d'horreur
où ça bouge tout le temps etc. là c'est vraiment lent, posé
mais c'était une très belle histoire
je vous remercie encore une fois et puis je
vous dit à très vite dans un prochaine vidéo.
portez vous bien, tchao tout le monde Peace